we're going austin yay
we're meeting up the big mood girls
we're gonna do a panel out there and
meet some of you guys and then we're
gonna go to dallas and then go to
orlando yeah it's a three-part trip
[Music]
it's our first flight of the family of
four
[Music]
i want to cry just looking at
[Music]
it smiling
[Music]
you love me already huh you love me yeah
[Music]
[Music]
so we're we're driving around jenny and
joe's property
they own six acres of land look at them
shirt
oh yeah glasses help too oh gross and
this is where the gator came out and
then you had an alligator on your
property yeah they killed it you made it
how do you
how do you let your kids play knowing an
alligator just no that's why we have the
safe line fence over there and they can
only play over there unless we are
outside watching them crazy it's too
boozy
for what look at that he has the broom
so he can sweep this
stuff
so this is his first time jumping in a
trampoline jumping in a trampoline we
held a song
[Music]
oh you blew it oh how fun can i do that
oh my god
you know i consider myself a lucky man
because i get to see my wife be an
overgrown child and it's one of the
cutest things about tiff and always a
great joy to see her just
act like a kid it's one of the many
facets that make her beautiful but real
quick we have been away from home for a
very very long time and one of the
things i miss the most is my bed huge
shout out to helix sleep for sponsoring
today's video we're super excited to
partner up with helix sleep again
because they make premium mattresses
customized to fit your needs shipped to
your door we got our first helix
sometime around last july and loved it
so much that when we decided to upgrade
our bed once again we went with helix
again we finally made the move to a size
bed this time the reason why is helix
created a quiz to figure out what type
of mattress is best for your sleep
preferences and your body type considers
if you're a back sleeper side sleeper or
even if you toss and turn they have
matches for you i'm one of those you
tell it your preferred firmness and
whether or not you wake up with back
pains but check this i also like how
they can consider preferences of not
just one person but two
people based on our results helix
matched us with their helix moonlight so
we've enjoyed our helix for over a year
now and with the most recent bed we've
had it for a couple months now and i
have to say it is the best sleep i've
ever gotten in my life i've always said
this about sleep which is i never
understood what bad sleep was until i
had good sleep and helix has opened my
mind to the possibilities of great sleep
for our newest bed in terms of firmness
we've selected the softest one literally
like sleeping on a cloud don't forget
they deliver straight to your door with
free shipping within the us and they
come in a box so it's super easy to set
up they also have a 100 night sleep
trial so you get more than three months
to make sure you love it if you don't
they'll actually come and pick it up
full refund plus mattresses come with a
10-year warranty they also offer
flexible payments and financing so good
sleep is never far away i absolutely
love my helix i think you will too check
out helix at a link below or visit
helixsleep.com
tiffcase and get up to 200 off your
first helix mattress plus two free
pillows and
okay that is it back to florida good
morning everybody today we are in
florida and yeah yeah where's ayden hey
aiden we got luca here got isaac here we
got mama here and we
[Music]
bank might be easier for luca to grasp
it's like
right at least that's the logic there
but i don't know
okay well then we're on the right track
we've been staying at jenny and joe's
house uh
i think it's really your aunt but but
okay closer to his cousin age other
people would say it's just my second
cousin i think so she's cousins with my
dad her mom and my grandma are sisters
that's how we're related anyway
family so we've been staying out here
since uh leaving texas oh yeah so we
finished our trip in texas by enjoying
july 4th all that stuff
did a little bit of house shopping i
don't know maybe we might be moving to
texas or we might be moving to florida i
don't know but we're thinking california
is too expensive these days i don't know
maybe we've been staying in california i
don't know we have actually just started
talking about the idea of possibly
moving who knows so don't take our word
for it might not even move we might stay
put the point is it's exciting to go
shopping and dream about steve yeah
dream of dreaming about a different
lifestyle that's really fun um but yeah
anyways today now we are going to the
beach and one of the most important
things about moving to florida if we
were to move to florida if we were to
move to florida okay is what are the
beaches like out here because we like
california because it has their beaches
la has everything we have beach desert
mountain we just don't have we have
forests we don't have like rainworks or
anything true
true they do have rainforests out here
though it's so wet out here it's like
like look at isaac's hair it's like
frizzy it's that florida humidity it was
actually hard to do my hair like it
can't just it's impossible anyways but
your skin is amazing my skin is amazing
no eczema in florida so that's a plus
and i'm thinking about that when i'm
considering where to move if we move but
yeah so we're going to the beach uh
we're gonna get some breakfast right now
and uh we're gonna go to cracker barrel
and we don't have cracker barrels out in
california so i'm excited wait what
there's a cracker barrel in california
i've never seen it i've seen them all
the time and i always point out and i
always say i've never been a cracker
girl oh my goodness we should go to
cracker bell barrel in there all right
well
i lie and you're right and we're gonna
try cracker barrel in florida it's real
it's really really good what's your
favorite thing there um the pancakes the
pancakes better than ihop
oh yeah oh yeah syrup's better even the
syrup's better yummy i like fried
chicken then i might get fried chicken
huh i have to try the uh grilled cheese
with strawberry juice oh yeah your old
isaac the light the i think the light i
like that and i hope you would always do
that i think we even vlogged it before
yeah we did actually it was a lot
younger i think the name of the vlog was
grilled chaser jam question mark
exclamation mark question mark
exclamation mark
[Music]
we are at the beach we are at clearwater
this is gulf water we went across the
whole state i'm like cool i've been
through like all the florida now in
miami all of florida pretty much yeah
there's a gator oh yeah there is an
alligator there's a gator over
[Music]
luca there what are you doing luka
you gave him cleavage the way you held
him just now
baby cleavage
[Music]
what are you guys eating
ice
that's delicious
yummy
what flavor is that
are you ready for the beach you look
like a little sailor he does look at him
hi
i'm turning your face
[Laughter]
it's gonna be your first time in the
ocean
in the first time in the ocean let's go
[Music]
oh i know it's not nice just kidding you
release this fish too look it's kicking
his head
hey
[Applause]
yeah luca is a boy or a girl
what a boy boy okay
[Music]
yeah you know what he is of yours
your cousin your cousin is your cousin i
like how you kiss him
can you let her go no you can't let him
go
get him i grazed my phone though
[Music]
[Music]